in this video we'll be talking about the
types of granules in neutrophils this is
a High video for usml step one so
neutrophils are the most abundant lucite
in our body and they are the component
of the innate immune system they play
crucial role against the immunity uh for
bacteria neutrophils are phagocytotic
and their level increases when you have
a bacterial infection in your body so
neutrophils are the most abundant
circulating
lucites in our body they are much more
abundant compared to other blood cells
like basophil or eosinophils Etc now
neutrophils do their function via
specific granules in present in their
cytoplasm and there are different types
of granules present in the cytoplasm of
neutrophil this heterogenity of the
granule has greater biological
significance which we would unreveal in
this video so let's see the
granules so so there are two most
important category of granules first is
primary granules they're also weirdly
called as azurophilic granules we'll
know why they contain most potent
hydrolytic enzymes just to give you some
example like elastase myop peroxidase
Etc then secondary or specific granules
contain high level of iron binding
protein such as lactofen they have other
enzymes which has very specific and
defined function for from an immune
context there are tertiary or gelatinas
granule which contains the enzyme
gelatinase and each of these granule
contents are really important for innit
immune response so let's talk about the
primary or azurophilic granules they are
the larger and the most numerous type uh
of granule among the granules present in
the neutr so you can see they stain
bluish purple color when stained with
lab D that is why they are known as
azurophilic then primary granules or
aurophilic granule contains proteins
which are toxic for
microorganisms and they are they play
the initial and non-specific response
against any infection the contents of
the azurophilic granules are myop
peroxidase then cathepsin G Proteus 3
defensin lyes elastis and many more
we'll try to look at some of these
components and try to understand how
this works for example one of the most
important component is myop peroxidase
enzyme
this helps in the process called
respiratory burst during the process of
respiratory burst oxygen is converted
into Super oxide Radical by the help of
enzyme nadph oxidase then Super oxide
dismutase converted into hydrogen
peroxide which further gets converted to
hydro HCL radical with the help of the
enzyme myop peroxidase so myop
peroxidase is important to generate the
reactive oxygen species now these
reactive oxygen species would
eventually kill the bacteria in various
ways that is why the contents of these
granules are really important now elas
is an enzyme that has uh various role in
terms of immunity many bacteria has
elastic components in their cell wall
and capsules that can be broken down by
this enzyme elas also eles helps in
tissue
remodeling now the now let's talk about
the secondary or specific granules all
these granules are nicely categorized
and described with the help of Straus
electron microscopy studies or
transmission electron microscopy studies
now these are smaller in size compared
to the primary granule and fewer in
number as well they contain protein and
enzymes uh with specific function such
as many of these uh contents of the
secondary granule helps in chemotaxis
phagocytosis or might have antimicrobial
activity now let's I mean overall the
goal is to fine-tune the immune system
so let's look at some of these
components such as lacto Lymes
collagenase Etc so for example lysosyme
that breaks down peptidoglycan layer of
the bacterial cell wall nadph oxidase
which is present in these um
granules produces super oxide radical
now we looked at that super oxide
radical or reactive oxygen species can
kill the bacteria when neutrophil has
engulfed it then lacto has antimicrobial
activity by sequestering free Iron so
all of these are content of the uh
specific granule or the secondary
granules now let's talk about another
important category called gelatinase or
tertiary granule which has gelatinas
enzyme which can break down the metrix
metalloprotein and they can overall
remodel The extracellular Matrix so it
is useful for tissue remodeling purposes
another category of granul which is
broadly defined but still debatable is
the secretary granules the secretary
granules are something which is secreted
by the neutrophils as the name suggest
now these are secreted by activated
neutrophils in response to an infection
most most of the components in these
secretary granules are chemokines and
cyto these are kind of like a backup
signal that the neutrophils are telling
the friends of their innate immune
components to give backup because there
is an potential invasion
let me take you to that scenario so
let's say there is a bacterial Invasion
macras and the neutrophil would
eventually be engaged with these
bacteria so macres secretes spe specific
components such as uh cxcl8 neutrophil
secrete components like cxcl 12 or 14
all of these help in the diapedesis of
many of the other uh immune cell
component such as more macras and more
nutrifil this helped them to be be
recruited into into the site of
infection that is why these granules are
super
important now defect in neutrophil
granules can be associated with many
disease for example Alpha granule defect
is associated with many BAC many
diseases and most common this is the
most common neutrophil defect the
antimicrobial activity of the neutrophil
is com not totally compromised but
partially compromised because there is a
defective HCL radical production this
has been seen uh with uh otop uh so this
is seen with AML disease then there is
cherc higasi syndrome which is a genetic
disorder where the list gene or losal
transport Associated Gene is basically
abrogated which lead to formation of
abnormal giant Alpha granules and this
has many other
consequences also nadph oxidase which
was a component of the secondary granule
is defective in chronic granulomas
disease or cjd which is again a xlink
recessive disorder in this case what
happens the ability of the neutrophil to
kill bacteria is compromised so we
understand if any of these granules are
defective then the neutrophil's ability
to function is compromised now all of
these granules are developed in
different timelines so it's important to
understand the neutr maturation timeline
and the appearance of these granules so
neutrophil matures like myoblast to
prosite myosite metam myosite band cells
and eventually the mature neutrophil all
these granules are not present
throughout the beginning for example
primary or azurophilic granules are the
first one to be present in these uh
neutrophils it is roughly present from
the myosite stage then the secondary
granules are present from the metam
myosite stage whereas the tertiary
granules are appearing at the later
point when the band cells are eventually
getting getting to a mature neutrophil
state so all these granules are present
in the body in different
timelines so just to summarize we looked
at two most important granule types in
the neutrophil those are azurophilic
granules or the primary
granules whose contents majorly are myop
peroxidase then cathepsin G proteinas 3
Lymes Etc it's important to note that
many of these uh contents of these
granules can be overlapping we also
looked at specific gran ules we looked
at gelatinous granules and secretary
granules which has alkaline phosphates
many of these chemokines Etc so I hope
this video was useful if you like this
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to like share and subscribe see
you in next
video